well guys this is the last time we're
ever going to see fat Jonah Hill no
please get the phone mom the phone's
ringing you hear it have you started
looking for a job yet the sitter stars
Jonah Hill and it's about a guy who you
know really shouldn't be a babysitter
but guess what he is it's a big old
night where he decides to be an idiot
and take these kids to all these places
like where they shouldn't be where
there's parties drugs and just stuff
where they should not be of course he's
got these annoying kids on the way one
of them likes to blow stuff up one of
them has an anxiety problems and the
other ones this little girl who just
loves make up and getting into trouble
what about babysitting babysitting sucks
adult men don't babysit things you're
wonderful with children
Jonah Hill is a charming actor I like
Jonah Hill I think that he's a good
actor he demonstrated that very well in
Moneyball I think he's funny too and
here I think he's funny as well and I
like him in this movie I think he gave
his character a good amount of heart I
liked some of the scenes in this movie
and I actually you know what I didn't
really mind this movie that much just
later life and Rodrigo babysitter I'm
more of a sit on the couch what's up
little tampon do whatever I say or I'll
kill you take a babysitter if you know
what you're getting into going in you're
not gonna be terribly disappointed with
this movie if you're expecting and like
laugh out loud
uproarious comedy where you leave the
theater like holding your stomach you're
not gonna get that either some of the
action is a lot more hard than you think
one of the things that actually really
surprised me a lot is I'm usually pretty
annoyed with kids in movies it takes a
lot for me to like a kid in the movie
and these three kids actually aren't
that bad I thought the kids and Jonah
have worked really well together that
that good rapport with one another and
some of the jokes worked for me wanna
come I probably shouldn't I was thinking
we could have sex yeah maybe I could I
could work something out random
characters show up very conveniently at
times and just save the day kind of and
you're like there is no way ever that
this person would ever just just show up
right when you need them I mean it's
just such a movie in that sense like
movie things happen you know where stuff
happens and you're like wow this is
definitely a movie just you know it
would never happen in real life of
course a really pretty girl likes the
fat guy which also very rarely happens
in real life I was fat once that's
besides the point I've been stuck
babysitting these three kids that looks
good what is that I'm beat
- insane drug dealers I came for my keys
to my minivan and that's what's up also
one of the things is whenever Jonah Hill
does something bad to someone like
steals or destruction of property it's
always conveniently someone that we as
the audience hate it's a jerk or just
too awful mean person like yeah it's
okay he messed up their car but he's a
jerk anyway so it's alright there's
things like that they're just very
unrealistic but honestly this movie
ain't that bad if you know what you're
gonna get going in I mean you're gonna
be satisfied the sitter gets a B -
what's your name they call me soso baby
so baby yeah you can in control baby
tears no fears man oh is that right
respect it don't neglect it alright my
bubble treated don't beat him oh my -
what's your favorite Jonah Hill movie
I'd like to know because he's a funny
guy and I think mine would probably be
Moneyball let me know down in stuckman
square you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and gets stuck
mine eyes